the dress code for the fundraiser is
fancy glam
grace fraser's fashion isn't just for
show it represents how she slowly comes
undone
the undoings iconic fashion moments
aren't only about wealth either
they represent how complex and fragile
grace really is
from eye-catching coats to that
mesmerizing maxi dress
here's what the psychologist's costumes
really say about her family's fall from
grace
but be warned there are some spoilers
ahead whatever secrets you continue to
harbor for her
it's my business grace's iconic green
coat paired with her wild hair
definitely give us witchy vibes designed
by sidney selland
the coat highlights how grace dresses
differently from her upper east side
friends
like sylvia grace's green coat is more
mysterious
while she definitely stands out green
also represents envy and how the
audience views grace as an elite
when her life starts to unravel the code
itself seems to ask us whether or not we
pity her
since she lives in such a privileged
world oh tell me i'm free to go
the coat also has a large hood that she
never actually wears
but exists for her to protect herself if
she needs to
but as we know from her father grace
never likes to explain herself
or ask for help i just need a little
unconditional support from my loving
father right now
that would be nice grace has many
choices of outerwear
which show off her bohemian style as a
rebellion from the status quo
walking by herself and standing out is
symbolic of her independence
the mix of colors she often wears while
still going so well together
also represent her indecisiveness in
stressful situations
this red coat is an example but pales in
comparison to her striking all red look
the rich red color obviously makes us
think of the gruesome crime committed
but also shows us how well grace can
pull herself together
the red tones exist harmoniously with
her red hair while
also mixing complementary colors and
fabrics i just want to ask a few
questions that's okay
of course we can't help but wonder why
all the long codes
they suggest that grace is fragile and
needs protection but that she also
might be hiding something i don't know
what i think
grace's gorgeous givenchy gown paired
with a royal embroidered cape
is one of her best fashion moments
before her life takes a terrible turn
at the fundraiser both her and elena
look like different versions of a greek
goddess
they're depicted as two sides of the
same coin both with wild hair
thank you for your kindness
the dress has a low neckline wide
sleeves and an open back
it's the most liberating look we see
grace in we notice that her chest is
very visible
which symbolizes her heart and love as
her weakness
grace complements the look with mauve
lipstick bringing out the dresses colors
they change depending on the lighting
like how the story continually changes
in our minds
and graces depending on who you believe
is guilty
she was upset like the maxi dress
grace's clothing is often made of soft
and feminine fabrics
but most of her body is covered and she
tends to wear sophisticated cuts
this satin suit is masculine despite the
soft flowy fabric
it represents her strength but also her
fragility
when she confronts her father about
believing in and supporting her
instead of vilifying her husband exactly
how weak do you think i am
grace's love of contrasting fabrics is
also highlighted with this silk blouse
and suede skirt combo she also wears
tights
not allowing any of her skin to show
she's not just protecting herself from
the cold
but also the reality of her
circumstances
this contrast is pretty obvious
throughout the whole series
this feminine fabric and cut in
particular is a good example of the
contrast between her fashion
and a high stakes moment are you okay
fine
i promise just as grace always covers
herself
scarves and bows offer a visualization
of her struggling to keep herself
together
the scarves which she wears from the
very first moment we meet her
and bows on her blouses all have nots
the symbolism of them coming undone
as she does or being undone highlights
her vulnerability
in essence the knots unravel as the
character does
there's a certain stigma attached to a
public defender
turtlenecks and high neck outfits also
offer protection
and grace wears them in almost every
scene the high neck
cuts illustrate grace's need to keep
everything inside
she's constantly holding onto herself
trying not to fall apart
like when she visits jonathan in jail i
would never take a human life
i don't know anything even when the
color stands out
turtlenecks are worn like a shield she
might still dress like an elite but
she's not willing to bare her neck
and show her true vulnerability i know
how close you and your dad are
grace is obviously a perfectionist only
offset by her wild hair
her jewelry is a huge element of this
perfectionism
her rings in particular are high-end but
dreamy
symbolizing her self-expression and
meticulous attention to detail
selland shared that one ring has a lion
on it
it's not very noticeable but goes to
show the subtle details that helped
create the character
and her undeniable strength especially
as a lioness protecting her child
let's go we're gonna be late for grandpa
the boots grace wears are also perfect
for her character arc
they're sturdy but elegant suede and
rich in color
they have heels and match her many coats
which illustrate more than needing to
wear boots in winter
she takes time to make sure that her
boots mostly hidden
are perfectly coordinated when she wears
heels to court however they're quite
different from what we usually see her
in
where were you then this cream-colored
look without black tights or boots is a
big change for grace
it's more understated but grace keeps
some of her personality on display with
the elegant details
this illustrates her discomfort with her
situation but also that court will end
up being the place where she can finally
speak the truth
and set herself free his grace fraser
2020's fashion icon
let us know which of her outfits is your
favorite in the comment section down
below
don't forget to hit that like button if
you enjoyed this video and subscribe to
our channel for more
thanks for watching
you